doing Marilyn I think that welcome thank
you great we are in quite the proofer
right here I guess we can get rid of
this yes baby yes baby sexist Texas
dropped me and you dude it let's go now
crash why did you crash alright I don't
know if you got I got a drill now whoa
oh wow oh okay we got a drill we got a
[ __ ] Ellis finish yes yes yes I want
the drill hey I don't need a gun well
shut up sorry I don't get it
okay there we go we got the drill baby
we're gonna drill here baby so that what
are you did he just turn into razor
blades
ah come on shut up lady babies don't run
come on
give me a break ah
thank God thank God the metro stations
was different somehow
nothing I could put my finger on I can
do it I'm doing it
but everything seems slightly up
slightly
you call that [ __ ] slightly well I
wouldn't call that slightly it was as if
the entire building had rotated just a
couple of Oh areas that I remember
walking were not closed off leaving me I
never the ship the feeling that unseen
force was guiding me down the pathway
doesn't usually I know where well [ __ ]
here we are again friends our plant
there at least it makes me feel good and
they have time
sorry time just have a problem with you
shut up Todd I never [ __ ] like you
did I I never liked you I never [ __ ]
like your type oh no no no no no no no
that's no bueno
why did I do it I tied this is why I
hate you tan right Dean right [ __ ] be
right [ __ ] shut up that's right you
don't mess with me fans okay wait I
actually have a gun I should probably
use it no actually no I don't have a gun
never mind no how do you [ __ ] fly
[ __ ] up
I [ __ ] die and I loaded the wrong
file genius parry strikes again you are
welcome normally locked all cash close
it's all crying and hadn't on computer
and slime condi face down no no no shut
up stop you made me do it bro I died how
to hit I thought I got him okay focus
kids
focus [ __ ] focus [ __ ] drilling its
face out all right
what's the plan here run for it bad plan
dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] up and die that's
good
hey don't [ __ ] with me I have a drill I
have a drill that's how we roll in
pewter pot town [ __ ] come in lady come
on Lady come my lady
Julia [ __ ] face Slater yes that's how
I roll a health pack would be [ __ ]
splendid right now
all right pitch you got a scab much more
for stuff
well no we're doing this a pity pie way
or the highway
I like hum referencing songs from like
the 90s that's good McDonald's day all
right what's the point of being up here
okay there we go
I might died go shut up Oh jump ruger ah
those little transporting
yes baby I need you
now take away the biggest part of me Oh
baby I'll put [ __ ] bullets in your
skull I'll be home soon
yeah half an hour more half an hour
solamente ah mont de baños and you're
alright
don't play mind games with me we're
playing an eclair bike whatever it's
called
not you think you're funny huh I hope
not hey shut up
not funny [ __ ] a quick save that I could
say hey let's watch Pete if I die a
million times
oh wait I'm home soon it's like every
single exercise now or more I have two
bullets is that it or two mags I wish it
was two mags
alright alright alright alright bro come
out I know you're [ __ ] in there come
out come out come out hey you want to
play all right
one what what what you're can [ __ ]
that's right and what's that what the
[ __ ] was that
shut up
shut up don't even worry about it all
right
down here maintenance excellent this is
totally totally oh shut up don't do it I
don't want to know I just want to go
home there's got to be a better way home
calm down
[ __ ] monsters come on I killed so
many give me a break
all right let's can we drill that little
baby yes we can and yes we shall let's
drill the mother [ __ ] maybe they're
still my baby girl oh you got one shot a
bit uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh that's how I roll
let's time I get all the loot
what yeah bow you [ __ ] bow this
[ __ ] room ever
that's right boughs [ __ ] are you doing
in here
[ __ ] off hi shut up [ __ ] battles don't
close the door
all right do what you got to do but
don't [ __ ] close it do it on me [ __ ]
look at my house this is not good
okay oh thank heavens
thank heavens what is that come here
wait a little [ __ ] oh I don't need you
prepared a if you collect them you got a
super ultra epic ending well I'm fine
all right who made that noise who made
that noise so one is snoring
Jew oh [ __ ] me ah dude that was a close
one
shut up shut up shut up shut up shut up
hmm stop singing bad song spits it's
getting a night okay where are we okay
okay what's the plan here bad plan
[ __ ] I can't I kind of failed on that
one a little bit don't even worry about
it
don't even worry about it I got this I
got this
okay okay shut up
nice is how I roll
that's how I get out a lady okay cool
wake up
we're cooler than cool is [ __ ]
barrels [ __ ] off
where is it is it here dad we didn't
check out wait we did check out I
thought there was
[Music]
oh what the
what what is
what
what just happened mmm berry king okay
what my little Ajira oh no no no no come
down come down I don't know I mean a box
that's one thing that's probably not
right okay I'm sorry
the box is fine I love this box oh
that's nice that's nice
oh hello hey how you doing okay shut up
lockers don't do that bow not come on I
[Applause]
don't even want to know what's
underneath there okay fine you know what
fine
yes baby yes baby sexist Texas okay
and it's semblance of logic arrays and
had fallen away I had become lost within
this place seemingly cut loose from any
landmarks of reality the horrors I can
see appear to be as memories act self
unspeakable cruelty and evil long since
committed but as yet unpunished
all right breast what the [ __ ] is that
in the next episode we will kill it I
don't know what it is but we will
[ __ ] kill it like a riddle if he
enjoyed catacomb a birthday and I see
you in next episode or whatever one
makes salesman
no I don't worry I got this
here you go man no no that was not a
solution all right Obama I get it right
Alec